it may be autumn but Cordova is in full
bloom eight top international florists
have let their imaginations run wild for
displays inside public courtyards across
the southern Spanish city flora is both
a competition for the artists and a
festival for the public this courtyard
features it work by Tomas Sabrina of
Belgium the internationally acclaimed
floral artist brought some 2000 as a
leas to Cordova I was inspired by the
Paradise in Cordoba so first of all I
used the possio possio it's paradise for
Cordoba and second I also used like a
filigrana Cordoba
that's the craftsmanship people really
loved it accord over so those two
together I want to have a dialogue with
the patio with the craftsmanship I wait
the festival to create a dialogue with
the people one day before the festival
opened he was still busy with 22
assistants who had just four days to
transform his vision into a floral
reality every detail matters
Tomas Sabrina is demanding we have to
redo it out yes out redo we need
perfection the edge between the plants
in the wall is like almost like three
centimeter four centimeters too wide so
they have to move all the plants three
four centimeters to the wall that like
everything is suits bell it's part of
the concept
a Chinese entrepreneur donated a total
of 120 thousand euros in prize money
awards are given to the three best
entries also in the running is Robert
Hornsby the creative director of
London's in-water flowers his works
provide food or flowers for thought
[Music]
reflections is basically looking at
yourself looking at your soul looking at
who you are where you came from what are
you doing are you happy I think when
people see themselves in the mirror it's
very challenging sometimes the ultimate
question is are you happy today am I
happy today
do I like myself the courtyard of the
Archaeological Museum is the backdrop
for an installation by Patrick Nadeau
from France a trained architect with a
passion for plants he counts companies
like MS and Louie Vuitton as his
customers he's particularly interested
in archaeology archaeology is the
history of civilization it's the history
of humankind of things or architecture
and all of that could only arise because
before there were humans there were
plants they're the source of life that
give us the air we breathe that's why I
find it so compelling to install a kind
of enormous vessel filled with plants at
the heart of an archeological Museum
[Music]
news about my yes is from Madrid she
used to work as a fashion designer but
for the last seven years she's been
designing floral artworks like this one
in the inner courtyard of Cordova's
bullfighting Museum
[Music]
this is an extraterrestrial garden from
another planet to get away from
traditional ideas of what a paradise
should look like
I didn't use any green plants and only
chose ones with unusual colors in this
way I hope to create a kind of dream
world
an imaginary world a fantasy ax Cordoba
is famous for its inner courtyards known
as patios hardly any other city in Spain
boasts as many on behalf of the city
Emilia Ruiz Mateo organized the
International Flower Festival flora and
brought the floral artists to Andalusia
patios of Cordoba play a central role
here they date from Roman times were
perfected by the Arabs and are just the
place for flowers that's what we wanted
to link this ancient culture with a
passion for flowers modern floral
creations surrounded by historical
architecture the prize for the loveliest
patio went to this installation designed
by two Americans the jury awarded Tomas
de Bruyne as patios second place and
40,000 euros in prize money the Belgian
floral artist has already jetted off to
his next assignment in San Francisco but
visitors can still admire his floral
paradise in Cordoba until the end of
October
[Music]
you